et j'ai des souvenirs de ouf ici tu sais
moi il y a quoi ici il y a peut-être 11
ans 10 ans mais 11 ans je crois j'étais
là c'était ma première c'était stressée
à notre place j'ai vomi j'étais pas
aussi à l'aise que toi et Jamel est venu
me voir il m'a dit mais c'est ton moment
qu'est-ce que tu fais c'est maintenant
ou jamais tu vas laisser passer ça
je suis monté il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé puis m'a attrapé il m'a dit
bienvenue dans la cour des grands
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens clairement de ta panique
je me souviens clairement de ton stress
et je me souviens clairement du carton
surtout que tu as fait et c'était
évident derrière c'était une autoroute
incroyable donc merci merci ça me fait
bizarre
[Applaudissements]